Oh, hello everybody!
Oh my god, this game is so fucking loud.
Give me a second.
Give me a fucking second.
Oh, I'm angry.
I'm sorry.
I'm so...
Today was awful today.
At least I'm a lot better now.
Like, I'm not coughing as much anymore.
Thank fucking god.
Um, let me... Oh my gosh.
I'm like...
This game is so loud.
I'm not gonna...
Alright.
Alright, story time.
Story time.
Okay, so... Yes, I was...
I forgot.
Okay, so...
I'm so sorry.
I wanted to relax today.
Cause, you know, they were doing like a schedule.
Like, um, power...
Electrical maintenance shit.
I think they were checking up on the other stuff that happened after the flood.
So they were like, you guys are not gonna have power for today.
And I was like...
That's like... There's no warning?
No warning at all?
So I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna go to the fucking...
I'm gonna go to the mall.
I haven't been there for like two years.
I'm gonna do it.
I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna treat myself.
I'm gonna...
I was like, I'm not gonna have any internet.
I'm not gonna have any internet.
I'm not gonna have any power.
I'm gonna fucking... I'm gonna treat myself.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go to this really nice, fancy mall.
That I haven't been there in two years.
They have the best crepes.
They have this place for crepes.
And I'm gonna get myself a crepe.
It's just a 20 minute...
Also, another reason why is that the mall is like 20 minutes away.
So I was like, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna take an Uber.
I'm gonna splurge.
I'm gonna get an Uber.
I'm gonna go to that mall.
I'm gonna get myself some fucking crepes!
And then, first off, they didn't have crepes.
I've been gone for two years.
I haven't been there for two years.
And who would've thought the crepe place went out of business.
The crepe place went out of business.
So instead, I got ice cream.
I- I got ice cream.
You didn't check?
I don't even remember like...
This place had the best crepes Clearly, not good enough because it went fucking out of business but back then It- I was- I'm gonna say that place, that crepe place has been there for ten years In the last two years I didn't go, it went out of business.
What happened two years ago?
Oh, COVID.
Goddamn COVID!
My crepes!
Why did people buy crepes during COVID?
I don't understand.
The crepe place has been there for 10 years!
Why couldn't people buy dessert during COVID?
Like, why?
They relied on you, Doki.
You didn't go and support them when they needed them.
How was I supposed to know they would just disappear?
They would just be gone?
How was I supposed to know that?
Also, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyone else ready for some anime?
Thank you.
Anyway, so yeah, I was super hyped.
I was like, I'm gonna go to this mall.
I haven't been there for two years.
It's only a 20-minute Uber ride.
Um, they have the fucking, they have a really good crepe store.
I'm fucking craving some crepes right now.
And I was like, oh, I'm so excited.
And I went there.
There was, there was no crepes, but it was fine.
I still explored the mall.
And I was like, wow, I have 40 minutes to come back before my stream.
So then I was like, the power said, the power schedule said it will be back up before then.
So like, it should be fine.
I ordered my Uber to come home.
It was...
Four, it was four.
I took the Uber at 4 10.
Because I was like, well, it took 20 minutes to get back.
So 4 10 is the perfect amount of time.
I forgot, I would...
I forgot people have real lives, chat.
I legitimately forgot like, what the real world was like.
I was like, what's the worst that could happen?
I was stuck in traffic for one hour, chat.
For one entire hour, I was in that fucking Uber.
I was like, why is there traffic?
And then I was like, oh yeah, people have jobs.
They say nine to five.
I thought they would get off at five.
What do you mean they get off at four?
I thought nine to five means exactly at nine.
What kind of... it's not nine to four.
Everybody says nine to five.
So like, what, why are they out now?
Why are students coming out now?
It's not students go home at three.
Why are people still driving?
There is a seven to four shift, Stokie.
Who fucking works seven to four?
Who works seven to four in my chat?
My nine to five lets me off at six.
Eight to four.
Who says eight to four?
I've never heard people say eight to four, but me.
You are the problem why I was late.
You are not joking.
I'm not joking.
Anyway, anyway.
So the day I decided to like go out.
Anyway, also like here's another lesson.
Going outside was a fucking mistake as a streamer.
Because I forgot what the real world was like.
Because I've been stuck in this like hyperbolic time chamber of like being a streamer.
And so like I forgot what people in the real world do these days.
Like I legitimately forgot rush hour was a thing.
Like, because I was like, why?
I was like, because I was looking at my google maps.
I was like, oh my god.
There's so many car crashes.
Because there's like reds everywhere on the google map.
So I was just like, what does that mean?
And I was like, wow, there's so many car crashes here on the road back.
And I was like, wait, it's just regular traffic.
And I was like, oh my god.
Oh, yeah, people have to go home.
I was like, why is there like three to four car crashes?
Like on google maps.
And I was like, oh, yeah.
People go home at this hour.
Chronically online.
So, so like going outside as a, as a streamer was a fucking mistake.
Because I forgot what the real world was like.
And because, and this is why I was late.
I legitimately was like, wow, 4 10.
Plenty of time to go home.
One hour.
I hate, okay, like being stuck in a car for one hour.
I was just, I, and it sucks because like, um, my, I get car sickness on and off.
Um, I get like, so like sometimes like if I'm in a small enough car, like if the car is small enough, like I get car sickness because like it's too small.
So it's like extra bumpy.
So like it's just not, and then like, you know, like when you're in stuck in traffic, it's like go stop, go stop, go stop.
So I couldn't like use my phone too much.
Because we're always like go stop, go stop.
So it's always moving.
And so like it like made my car sick even, even worse.
And I'm chronically online.
So I felt like I was in hell.
Like I was like, you know, like I got itch, like I was going through withdrawal and I was like, oh my god, just one last hit guys.
Oh, come on.
Just one last hit.
It's okay.
It's not like I'm gonna throw up or anything.
Oh, come on Doki, just, just browse the internet one, for one more minute.
Oh, it's okay.
I don't want to talk to my, oh, just one last, come on.
Oh, it's gonna be okay.
It's gonna, it's gonna, it's gonna be okay.
I'm gonna, I just, I just need to type just five more words.
The internet withdrawals.
So, so it was fucking, oh it was hell.
It was hell.
It was hell in that, oh, I'm never, I'm never going back to that mall again.
It's gonna be another two years to go back to that mall.
It's all because of that fucking mall's fault.
I already lost everything I wanted there.
Like, they don't even have my crepe store.
I don't care.
They don't need my business anymore.
Nekka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Doki.
As a worker of the seven to four hours, I always have a commute of two hours every day.
Wake up at 4 a.m to get to work at 7 to 4, then reach home at 6 p.m.
Easy day for middle of wage.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for like a quarter of your minimum wage.
I'm, sorry.
And here I am, commute, complaining about a one hour commute.
Sorry.
For real, but it affected me, guys.
You don't understand.
That one hour commute affected me.
Thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you.
So, um, today...
Today, we're gonna be playing...
Uh, we're gonna be playing...
Um, Animate Bejeweled.
Otherwise known as Honey Pop.
Look, I know a lot of people are very confused as to how the fuck...
Am I gonna do this?
And that is a very good question.
Because I want you guys to know, I'm literally going into this game Extremely blind With like no knowledge of like the actual gameplay and and like where it goes Like all I know is that there were anime girls and then there was it's bejeweled.
That's all I know about Honey Pop I didn't realize by the way It's banned on Twitch.
So
This game you're not allowed to stream it on Twitch And all like legitimately if you stream it on Twitch your account gets banned But then I didn't know that until like I put it on my schedule Because I in my head I was like Markiplier and Jacksepticeye and PewDiePie And all these other stream youtubers Made let's play of this video game 10 years ago Wait,
is Honey Pop 10 years old?
Wait Honey Pop Okay, honey, when did Honey Pop come out guys?
Wait a minute.
How old is Honey Pop?
Oh my god.
Okay 10 years ago They made let's play videos of Honey Pop 10 years ago and 10 years ago their audiences were like 13 years old to like 16 that was like their you know, that was their audience pool at that time 10 years ago 13 to 16 year old people Like they were like teenagers So I in my head I was thinking Oh It can't be that bad I was like it can't be that bad
I did That was a mistake because a lot of people were like Jokey, did you know the world is actually?
Not just anime beach world.
It is hentai beach world and I was like Excuse me I was like how did they How did they get away with that Their audiences were like teenagers back then I was like, what what do you what do you mean?
What do you what do you mean?
What do you mean?
It's what do you mean?
It's a porn game.
I Why was it so popular?
Why did youtube?
I was like I hate it.
How did this happen?
Um, anyway, we're gonna be doing it live.
I don't know I I don't I don't know.
I i'm just hoping I have a sensor ready So like I don't know when it's gonna hit but like the moment I see a little Anything the moment I see anything i'm fucking popping that shit up.
I'm I It's gonna be a it's gonna be like got Gotcha like am I when I open open something is it gonna be a titty like
All right, I have three sensors ready just so you guys know I got I got three ready for this wild adventure today So I I don't know when it's gonna hit.
I don't know where it's gonna be.
I don't know I I have no I have zero knowledge.
I just Everything i'm going here are my sensors, by the way, let me let me show you guys what it is
I'm trying to get them.
Okay.
I'm trying to find where is it?
I'm trying to find all right here.
Here's one of them this is sensor number one, I assume this is This is the appropriate size for like a titty like
I I okay here.
These are my sensors.
I've got we're just It's it's it's perfect size.
It's a perfect shape too because it's a circle So like like this it's a circle so it's a perfect size and then here's like number three as well So I have three sensors ready just in case If anything happens we have we have these guys To clutch it up for me We need a bigger to me how how exposed is this I assume it was just circles What do you mean?
It needs to be bigger?
How okay.
Okay, we're gonna have a problem
Okay, we'll put this one as our our big guy He's gonna be our biggest boy here right here These are our biggest sensors this guy Right here.
Let me make sure I crop it so I can Oh my god, this is Oh my god, this is gonna be a problem It's gonna be a problem Okay.
All right.
We're ready.
Okay, we're we're ready.
This guy is our main our main sensor This is gonna be the main the main guy and then these will be for the for the twins I'll have these guys for the twins and then this will be the main sensor.
All right, we should be good We should be good.
I hope diego.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Welcome All right Okay.
All right.
Let's get this game in honey pop.
Oh my god.
This oh my god.
This is gonna be such a problem
I Guys I legitimately guys.
No, you don't understand.
I legitimately thought this was gonna be like I you don't understand.
I thought it was I thought it was like a Pg-13 game.
I there were so many youtubers that there were so many youtubers that did Let's play of this and their audiences were teenagers like how how did they get away with that?
I don't understand like How did they get away with it Like I never watched it because I just I never had like, you know, I never had a reason to Okay, let's make sure our chat i'm gonna Looking resize our chat too.
I might as well.
Oh my god.
I'm so
The wild wild west right now All right, let's see.
I wonder if the chat gets cut off.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right, and then we'll make it longer too Might as well All right Here we go Let me know if the chat is is the chat cut off or is everybody fine okay, three 90 Oh my god.
All right.
Here we go.
This is fine.
I hope chat is Not cut off.
All right.
There you go All right Okay Welcome to the wild The wild wild west where anything can happen.
All right, do we start as male or start?
Does it does it matter does it change anything warning there is also voice acting during wait Wait, where did he go?
Zeke?
Where did you go?
Why did you finish your sentence?
How would I know?
No, he died before he could finish the sentence Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He died before he drank the wine
How would I ever know They caught him.
Oh my god, they got him.
It was too late.
We'll never know They never know
Oh my god All right, we'll do I don't know.
I don't know if I want to start.
Let's start as we'll start as male.
Fuck it
Sunday night, we're at the bar and lounge.
Let's go.
Oh, hi there.
Hey me What the fuck just approach?
Ah, no, this is awkward.
I don't like it when people randomly approach me Hello Hello, ma'am, um Your your dress is whoa.
Whoa Whoa, your dress is like almost coming off.
I think I'm in love with you.
Sorry.
I just don't talk to...
Sorry, I'm just very socially awkward.
I was stuck in traffic for an hour, so, um, sorry.
I'm not used to talking to women right now.
Oh, oh, um, cute?
You mean like the letter?
Yeah.
Not like that?
Yeah, no, I'm a mess.
No, how did you... yeah, I'm a mess right now.
I didn't realize this was a hint.
I'm a mess, ma'am.
I'm fucking a little frazzled at the moment.
I don't know what to do.
No, I'm... I... I just, uh...
Okay, um...
Shit, yeah, you're so... I mean, it's so hard to talk to you.
You are really pretty.
You are, though, not gonna lie.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's not how you talk to women.
It is?
You think the ladies love that I'm stumbling?
That I have negative riz right now?
Oh shit, sorry, I'll bring it back up a little bit more.
Oh shit.
Oh, she's gone.
Wait, my bedroom?
Oh my god, you definitely nailed it.
Oh my god, is that cute?
Guys, how is a negative riz?
How... guys, how does a negative riz if she came back to the bedroom with me?
Checkmate.
Check fucking mate.
Doki.
Hey Doki, is this stream safe to watch at work?
Asking for a friend...
Oh, it's very safe.
Don't worry, Cypher.
In fact, you should put it at, like, a high volume so all your co-workers could watch with you.
Thank you for the super chat, Cypher.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh, Yankee, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's my birthday today.
Thanks for playing Honey Pop on such a day.
Best gift ever.
Thank you for the super chat, Yankee.
Thank you.
Let's give a happy birthday before we go next, because I don't know...
I don't know what's gonna happen after this.
Like, I'm a little worried.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Yankee.
All right.
Oh, I was having...
All right, I'm...
Oh no, please.
Please, I... I don't know what I'm wearing.
I don't know if I'm wearing pajamas right now.
I'm afraid everything's a mess.
Yeah.
Wait, how did you get here?
Wait, exactly.
How did you get here?
My chat told me I'm negative Riz, but clearly, they're wrong.
See, guys?
They're so wrong.
I knew I had positive Riz.
How else was she in my... How else is she in my bedroom?
Hey, huh?
Did you... I mean, did...
Did we?
You and I?
Oh my god.
People said, like, you know...
Yeah, people said that, like, you know, I'm below her, but, like, look what happened.
You just gotta be funny.
If you're funny, you can get any girl or guy you want.
A love fairy?
Okay, but fairies... Fairies aren't real!
What do you mean?
Fairies are fake.
You see, as a love fairy, it's my job to help poor saps like you.
Poor saps?
It's just... What I do.
I don't like to rap.
Guys, no, no, she... Guys, she doesn't mean that.
All of my previous clients are basically walking bay magnets now.
You know that.
Wait.
Let's just say you will be my greatest accomplishment.
Wait, as in, like...
Wait, wait a minute.
As in, like, you're gonna improve my Riz that's already really good.
That's what she means, guys.
She's saying that she's gonna work so hard that my Riz, which is, like, you know, above average...
Is now gonna be, like...
Like, it's like when you go from, like, a B+, because you're an above average student, to an A.
That's, like, what she means, chat.
That's not...
She's... She's trying to say she's gonna make me, like, honor student, you know?
Um...
Um, yeah, it's... You're...
I'm having a hard time accepting the fair thing.
It's sort of, like, you know, it's not... I'm getting unimbursed right now.
And...
Wait, where do you wanna help me?
What's in... Yeah, where do you wanna help me?
What's in it for you?
Wait, I'm doing just fine on my own.
Yeah, wait, wait, no, thanks, but no thanks.
I'm... All I'm saying...
Is that I think I'm doing just fine on my own.
I don't need extra help.
Wait, what?
Oh, like, um, I... You know, like...
The f... You know, it's... It's... It's such a huge amount, that, like, numbers can't comprehend the amount, you know?
Oh my God, it's worse than I thought, isn't it?
Wait, why?
I literally...
It's so many that I can't even give a number.
You love it.
Or not, I don't care.
Sure, bro.
Like, I lost count.
I just... I just lost count, you know?
What do you mean read right... Wait, I'm going straight into Patron?
This is the date grid.
Date grid?
This is fucking visualed.
Learn affection by matching three or more of the circular tokens horizontally or vertically.
For a successful date, you have to fill the affection meter before you run out of moves.
Wow, I love visualed.
Match those orange ones with the crescent shape in the middle of the grid.
How the f... do I change this?
Where's the settings?
Okay, there we go.
Oh my gosh, she loves it.
No, Toki, it's the date grid.
Sexuality token?
Wait, what?
Which one's the sexuality?
Wait...
Wait, guys, I wasn't paying.
I thought it was just bejeweled.
What color was it?
I didn't...
I didn't realize there was more to it.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, there.
There you go.
Extra steps?
Oh, passion.
So, like, red is lust and pink is passion.
Okay,
so we can't match the broken heart.
GoldenEye, what the f... is that supposed to mean, GoldenEye?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
I'm gonna pass every f... date.
Guys, I paused it, Riz.
All right.
Oh, I got a gift!
Sentiment was...
The teardrops, okay.
Okay, we need on the leftmost column.
Okay, we got this.
All right, easy.
Sentiment.
Oh.
There you go.
Are we getting... Don't.
This is a question stream now.
So you can use them on your next...
Where are your eyes at, chat?
Where are your eyes at?
Okay.
Where were those eyes at?
Wait, don't think I didn't know.
Don't think I didn't know where those eyes were.
I could see where they're at.
All right, let's play bejeweled.
I'm not thinking right now.
I'm just... I'm moving.
Is it... It's working technically.
I'm not... There's no broken hearts.
I'm bejeweling.
I mean, this is the easiest date of my life.
Oh my god.
Out of my, you know, millions of dates, you know, millions.
This is the worst.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
Let's just bejeweled this.
What else?
Okay, hearts here.
What do you mean I'm gonna fail?
Everything's gonna be okay.
That's how you play bejeweled.
You don't think.
You just do.
That's like... That's just how you riz.
You just... Oh, no.
Oh, no, they're all broken hearts.
Whoa.
How am I cooked?
There's so many.
Look, I got sentiment and then...
Um...
And then there's like heart.
And then, uh, there's the the lust and then passion.
Um...
More moons, affection.
Okay, and then...
Passion.
There you go.
See, we're almost there.
What do you mean long stream?
I'm avoiding all the broken hearts right now.
And then here... And I did it.
I did it.
I... You just gotta believe.
Flask guy, thank you for the super chat.
The very first super chat.
Thank you.
Um, how did this stream happen?
Best of luck on the...
I... I just... I didn't know.
I just...
I...
I didn't know.
Okay, we're gonna... Wait, I need to fix... Adjust the sound.
All right.
Goodbye, fair.
My game saved.
So, like, I'm gonna go back to the main menu.
You can tell this game was 10 years ago.
I have to manually go back.
I have to close the game and go back to the main menu.
Okay.
Here you go.
I can't believe this game was 10 years ago.
All right.
Settings.
What do I have to do?
Sound effects low.
I'll do background music and sound effects low.
So then we can bring up the...
voice acting.
This should be good, right?
By the way, I didn't mark the stream R18, so this is gonna be the real test, guys.
If the stream was over and, like, and then YouTube marks this... All right.
You know, YouTube marking the stream R18 is, like, is, like, my ideal.
Like, the best case scenario.
Yeah.
The worst case scenario, like, is, like, I'm on their list.
As long as...
As long as I'm not on a list on... at YouTube.com, that's fine.
Like, at best, it's, like, they mark it R18.
The worst, I'm on a list, like...
Oh, the honeybee.
Oh, I got the honeybee!
Oh, god.
Isn't that... Am I a stalker?
Like, they said I'm a big boy.
Oh, my god.
I'm a big boy.
Oh, man.
Get that honeybee.
Oh.
To blow your nose, guys.
To blow your nose and other various bodily fluids, that means your tears, guys.
It means your tears.
The one other... There's no other fluids.
It's your tears.
Your tears and your nose.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna lie.
Back then, before... What's his name?
The guy for Hefner?
Before Hugh Hefner died, Playboy was actually...
Look, I never read Playboy.
I'm just saying, I knew from this from, like, the internet.
Not that I looked at Playboy, but I'm saying that, like, Playboy actually had a lot of really good articles unrelated to what it was known for.
If you guys didn't know that, they actually had, like, science articles, psychology articles, and, like, actual studies in Playboy, which is crazy to think about because there's, you know, their whole brand is, like, you know...
Ladies.
It was, it was, like, actual, like, it was, like, a mag- it was, like, an educational magazine that just happened to have naked women in there.
So that's all, that's all I'm gonna say.
I know that, but I didn't know this was a fucking hentai game.
Okay, oh, or we could just play video games, you know?
I said, let's go talk to some broads.
Um, they are women.
At least call, at least, you know, be proper about it.
Respect the ladies.
You can't just call them broads.
Look, see, positive res there.
Or we just chill and play video games.
Or we just chill.
We can't chill!
All right.
Just do this.
Wait,
where did they go?
Express?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, where do they- oh, they have the university, the mall, the gym, the park.
I want a smart lady.
Not the shopping mall, that means she shops and like, I like money.
I want a smart- or, or we could go to Downwood Park.
So like, she could be like, down to earth.
And then like, she likes homemade gifts more.
So like, we could save money together.
Uh
Okay, all right, let's go to- no, but then she'd be like, she'd be somebody that likes to go outside.
And like, I don't want to go outside anymore.
Let's not go- let's go to the cafe.
Let's do the cafe.
No.
All right, university or cafe, because I don't want to go outside.
I'll do the university.
She'd be smart, you know?
All right, nice.
I'm ready.
Also, does it sound better now, guys?
All right, my bedroom to university.
Let's go!
Oh shit, okay.
Oh, oh!
Whoa!
Oh, that's a teacher?
Oh my god, okay.
Um, there's me.
Oh my god, do I want a woman?
Or- or me.
Am I egotistical?
Or a woman?
Oh my god, Ms. Yumi.
Whoa.
Oh, you mean like- oh to be fair, two buttons are a button here.
But like, a teacher was wearing booty shirts, like...
Wait, I'm crazy?
Oh, okay.
Oh, thank god.
I was like, wait, what?
Oh, she's like, get the girl next door!
Get the girl next door!
Whoa, okay.
Um...
Hey.
It feels weird because I'm clearly not a student.
So it feels weird to lie to her and say I'm a student.
That's like a little weird.
So like, the other two choices aren't as great, but like...
Maybe she likes to be complimented.
I like to be complimented.
Chat, compliment me.
Wait, no, you are cute!
You're me!
Oh, no, I'm just trying to pick up girls.
Uh...
Um, okay, uh...
No, but if all the girls here are as cute as you, I might have to reconsider.
You know, I was thinking about going to Harvard, but then, like, they don't have you there.
What?
You're crazy.
Oh, no.
Oh, she likes it!
Guys, she li- oh my- Guys, all I'm s- Guys, I told you I don't need help.
How is that negative riz?
She likes it!
She literally likes it!
How is that negative riz?
Um, if I end up going here, you'll just have to show me.
I'm literally in right now.
Um...
Okay,
all right, all right.
We're not- We're not gonna- We're not gonna be creepy, guys.
We're not- We're not gonna be creepy.
So we're gonna go be like- Sorry, am I holding you up from getting in the class?
You know, I'm being considerate.
I'm being considerate now.
No, don't worry about it.
I'm all done with classes for now.
My name is Tiffany, by the way.
She gave me her name.
She gave- She gave me a- She added me on her phone.
She gave me her number.
I didn't!
I didn't even need your help!
I went by sheer intuition.
We're so- The bar is so- Her standards are low, Doki.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh!
The girl finder screen?
Oh my god, my stocks are going up right now.
All right.
It's a time- Before I forget, the money you earn during our date, you can use that to buy gifts, food, and drinks using the store app on the Honeybee.
It'll even detect which gifts the girl you're talking to prefer and will mark them with an icon.
All right, let's see.
All right, uh...
Girls.
Girl finder.
Shit, is it that time already?
No, wait!
I- No, wait, what?
I'm gone!
Shit!
I- I- I didn't realize it goes insta- All right, we'll- We'll do two.
We'll- We're ready.
We'll do two.
We'll- No, I wanted to talk to- Oh, shit!
Okay.
Hello?
No!
I fumbled it!
I fumbled it so fast!
Well, I think I have just the thing.
I didn't realize it instant transmissions me to her.
Nothing like a little exercise to melt that stress away.
Uh, not today.
I was in!
I was so in!
I'll be there.
I don't think I have anything else going on for once.
Great.
Can't wait.
See you there.
Dude, bro.
Yo, shit.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Dude, pro-age.
I have like the worst case of yellow fever.
Ever.
Guys, this was written ten years ago.
This is a tough approach.
She's kind of- Okay, I'm just- Doing something stupid to try and cheer her up.
It doesn't matter what.
The stupider, the better.
Stupider?
Okay, guys.
All right.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Doki knew it's at this moment.
Doki knew she fucked up.
Oh my god.
Um...
What are these?
What are these replies?
Why I- why I would never- what are these?
Fuck these- Fuck these birds.
Am I right?
She thinks I'm funny!
I like the birds.
Oh my god, she thinks I'm- she laughed.
Guys, if she laughs, you're in.
If she don't- But Doki, you're always laughing.
I'm only kidding.
I just thought you were cute and wanted to meet you.
Nah, I just like to bother people who look like they want to be left alone.
But for- what are these fucking- What?
What are these options?
But for- okay, I'll be not a creep.
But for real, what's up?
You look a little bummed out over there.
Oh, UOG?
It's the only university?
How small is the city?
A teacher?
You must be really smart.
Oh, yeah.
What do you teach?
Oh, so you got a sexy teacher angle.
What if I go through?
Guys, guys, whatever.
It can't be that bad.
Like, guys, all I'm saying- It can't be that bad.
Guys, I'm gonna do it.
I'm- It's- it's either- I bet it'll work, guys.
It's gonna work, guys.
Bro, it's gonna work.
Like, she seems like the type of woman that would be like, oh, you're so silly, you know?
You'd be like, I'm gonna do- I'm going all in.
I don't know about that.
I have a couple students who might agree with you, though.
You hear that giggle?
You hear that?
Guys, I'm in.
Oh my god.
We're so in.
You heard that giggle?
Oh, okay.
Let's check her profile.
Most desired sex- I fucking knew.
I was like, I- I knew it.
It's like- It's like in How I Met Your Mother when it was like, was it the naked man?
So like, it's like, you know, you go naked and either the woman rejects you or like fucking files a restraining order.
It's like this.
It's like 50-50.
So- So it's like in How I Met Your Mother and like, this is 10 years ago.
So it was basically like 10 years ago, Laura.
So basically, it's either she's gonna- she's gonna fucking say yes or like, it's over.
It works two out of three times, exactly.
All right, talent.
Least desired- okay, as long as I'm not talented, that works.
That's not- that's not- Oh, okay.
Whoa, okay.
She- whoa, okay.
Um, she is- whoa, okay.
All right.
Um, well she- oh, she likes it when you flirt with her.
Okay.
All right.
That's- that's good.
Okay.
Whoa, okay.
This is gonna be- all right.
Let's- whoa, okay.
There's- I- I never got this far before.
I can't- how do I give her an entire country?
I- I don't know.
It seems like I have to- I have to buy her a fucking entire country.
So, oh my gosh.
Okay, I gotta figure out how- how to- how to fucking gift her a country too.
Okay, uh, no, I never got this far.
I'm gonna talk with her.
I'm gonna interact with her.
Okay, um, what would you say?
I gotta know.
No, I shouldn't.
I already pushed it in the last question.
Um, what's your favorite place to hang?
Oh!
Oh no, she's a gacha player.
Oh no.
You can't stop those people from their dailies.
Let's go gambling!
Okay.
Oh fu-
Oh shit, um.
Oh, we're at that- okay.
I- you know, I didn't- I didn't think we were gonna- we're there yet, but oh, um.
Oh shit, okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
I- I can't.
I gotta talk to Tiffany.
She's a little too forward, guys.
I- I'm not ready for that yet.
It's- I- oh, I- you know, I- I- I- I didn't expect it to go at that level already.
I thought we were still doing small talk.
And um, I need- I need to be like- I need- I need to build up to that.
And I'm like, I'm not there yet right now.
Oh my god.
Bro, the first thing I asked was, what's your favorite place to hang out?
And then she went straight to like, hey, where did you not fuck?
The first time you meet some- that is not small talk.
That is not- How do I- how do I do this?
Okay, I'm gonna talk with her.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna- hey, so.
Um, what are you studying in college?
Well, I haven't really decided on a major yet, so I'm just getting my core classes out of the way.
Wait, what did she say?
I was hydrating.
Guys, what- What is her hot- what does she- guys, I need- you guys are my notebook, guys.
You guys are my notebook.
What does she study?
Oh, she has no major.
Okay.
Okay, I'm worried that this is gonna be on the test later.
So like, I'm trying to make sure.
I'm trying to make sure this is not gonna be on the test.
I'm not a bad listener.
I was- wait, what?
Oh, do you still- what the fuck?
Do you still talk with any of your- Oh, no.
What are these options?
God, no, those sluts can get bent.
Yeah, I keep in touch with some of them.
Well, that would require having a- had a girlfriend.
What?
What are these options?
Why can't I just be like, no?
Oh my god, she likes to flirt.
Oh my god.
I- none of these are like flirtatious.
Like, they're- Um, oh no, um...
Um...
What answers would you want me- Maybe if I'm pathetic, she likes that, right?
You think she'll like it if I'm pathetic?
Oh.
You don't- I just want it to be a little beta for you.
Okay.
Um...
I don't know how ugly are we talking.
Probably not, I need to be attracted.
Of course, looks aren't everything, you know.
That seems like she- she likes that.
Like, she doesn't like sexuality.
You think so?
I'm trying to be a good person.
What do you want from me, Tiffany?
What's your profile?
You're- Oh, she likes Raven.
I'm trying to be a good person.
Like...
Oh no, bro.
Why is- Why is her standards higher than the teacher?
I- Oh, she's a cheerleader.
Okay.
I am so hungry right now.
Oh, you're hungry?
Um...
Do I have food for you?
Uh...
What?
Food.
Okay, that's like...
Girl, talk to- I need to be a bad boy.
All right, it's time to be a bad boy for Tiffany.
Um, do I have money?
Okay, I have a thousand dollars.
Um...
Okay, she- she likes a bad boy.
So I'm gonna give her...
I'm gonna get her a- I'm gonna get a chocolate.
Wait, what's your favorite food?
Wait, she says what her favorite food is, right?
Favorite food.
Breakfast and candy.
Okay.
Yeah, I knew it.
I knew- I knew you're a bad- You're- You're- Okay, Bubble, come on.
Guys, I can't- Guys, I can't just give her good food right off the top of the bat.
We gotta- Wait, how do I give this to her?
How do I- I want to give you this.
How do I give this?
Please...
Stop.
I- I want to give this to you.
Down there?
Where?
That's the trash can.
I'm not gonna throw it away.
Bottom bar?
There's no bottom bar.
What are you talking about?
The lower inventory?
This?
Oh, exit phone.
No, I can't exit the phone?
Behind that window?
Where?
Wait, don't- don't- don't fuck with me.
I can't- I can't- I can't- I can't click out of the way!
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god, there you go.
Okay, we got this.
All I can think about is food.
You still- oh my god, okay.
Oh shit, okay.
Oh my god, she's- She's a gold digger.
Wait.
It's literally just gum.
No, but she wants so much more.
She wants so much more.
She wants food.
She's hungry.
She's like, oh, I'm so hungry.
All right, it's just- It's four hundred dollars worth of- okay.
All right, if she doesn't give me a date after I bought her four hundred dollars worth of pancakes, I'm- Like, even the teacher doesn't ask me for stuff?
Question time.
Oh shit.
Extraterrestrial stuff, you know, like aliens and that.
Oh my god, I don't know what she wants from me.
Like, the teacher was so easy.
I just gotta be stupid.
Then she'd be like, I can fix- She'd be like, oh my god, I'm gonna take care of this boy.
But like, I don't know what she wants from me.
I'll believe it when I see it.
They're real, believe me.
I was visited once when I was a kid.
You'll never know what's up there.
She doesn't like it when I'm smart.
She doesn't like it when I'm a good person.
So like, as a bad boy, I should be like, I believe it when I see it.
Okay, good.
Oh, thank god.
My friend Nikki is like obsessed with- Thank god.
She's nuts.
Thank god.
Okay, she hates nerds.
Okay, that's good to know.
That's good to know.
She doesn't like nerds.
Okay.
What do you want to know about me?
All right, I want to know...
Um, what's your favorite place to hang out?
I know it's boring, but I kind of just like to hang out around campus.
Oh shit, I learned.
All right, we're on a date.
I gave you $400 worth of pancakes.
I guess I've got some time.
Yes!
Let's do it.
I'm in.
Oh my god, I knew it.
I knew I'm not a loser.
Knew it.
I knew I'm not a fucking loser.
My friend Nikki would love this.
She's really into games.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
Okay, um...
Anyway, bejeweled time.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
No think, just bejeweled.
Surely nothing could go wrong if I don't enter- don't figure out every single move I do.
Like...
Look at that.
Okay, um...
And then we put it here.
Plus one set.
120.
Okay, she likes green.
Okay.
All right.
That's a good- that's- thank you for telling me that.
That's actually- that's really good to know.
Okay, we'll put this here.
Uh...
And then get the red over here.
And...
Don't spam.
It's too late.
It's- It's too late.
Don't keep- Don't keep what someone asks for a piece of juicy- This gold taking bitch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I had to buy that gum.
It don't- wait I have moves!
Oh shit!
Okay, JK I have nine moves left.
Oh I forgot about the moves.
I- Oh my god, I forgot.
I forgot about the boobs.
Oh shit.
I just realized that was a thing.
Oh, that's my bad.
That's actually my bad.
I finally... this is bejeweled.
This is bejeweled.
Oh no, my date!
My date!
Okay, oh my god.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh fuck.
Oh shit.
So, it's not over!
This is salvageable.
This is fixed.
I can fix this.
It's not that bad.
It's not that bad, guys.
Is it a bad time to mention I've never played bejeweled?
Is this a bad time?
Is it noticeable, chat?
Is it noticeable that I've never played bejeweled, guys?
I didn't know that, you know, there's like limited moves.
I didn't realize that was a thing.
Oh fuck, okay.
Alright, let's figure this out.
Okay, that's good.
We needed that.
And then...
Yeah, from the start.
It can't be that bad.
It's fixable.
It's actually fixable.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh shit, okay.
We're so close.
It's salvageable, guys.
Oh my god, two moves.
This is the biggest two moves of my life.
That's three.
I did it.
I am winnable.
I saved... I'm the coolest guy she's ever known.
Chat, I told you.
I'm so fucking cool.
I barely got it.
Let's go.
I'm so fucking cool, guys.
Alright.
Every date you go on is gonna be more challenging than the last.
If you don't improve your traits, you're gonna blow it.
Trust me.
You can use the honey you earn from interacting girls to upgrade your traits using the trait app.
Pay attention to the appetite meter.
A girl gets hungry standing around chatting all day.
If she's hungry, check the store to see if there are any food items that she might like.
Okay, if I talk to her too much, she's gonna get too hungry.
Okay.
Guys, is the volume a lot better now?
Chat?
Fails chatting, fails date.
This would be a lot... I didn't fail the date.
You guys hear her now, guys?
Also, Enon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, that's good.
That's good that you can hear her now.
That's good.
Alright.
Oh, she wants me, guys.
Guys, I'm so in.
I'm so in, guys.
I'm gonna talk to this girl now.
I spent $500 on her.
I'm gonna talk to this other lady.
Oh, she's at... Oh, it's me!
Do you prefer one... What do you do, like, for... Oh, wait, no.
We know she's a teacher.
Do you prefer one season over the others, ma'am?
If I had to pick, I'd probably say autumn.
I'm a sucker for all the colors.
Autumn!
I learned about her favorite season!
I'm in.
I'm so in.
Alright, we got upgrade.
The fuck am I gonna do with a flute?
What the fuck are these... Okay, can I... Oh, I can't upgrade anything.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I don't need to upgrade anything.
Okay, she likes me when I'm pathetic.
Okay.
No, she...
I'm, like, in her mind right now, guys.
The reason why I'm doing really well with her is that...
Guys, I'm not, like, on her wavelength or anything.
I just, like...
I'm just in her mind.
I'm just... I'm literally mind-reading her.
Alright.
What did you study in college?
Same.
I regret it.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm sorry.
Oh, whoa.
Yes, ma'am.
Okay, fruit and veg.
Okay, yes.
Yes, ma'am.
I'll buy you the food, ma'am.
Okay, ask on a date.
Alright.
Hi.
First date with the professor.
We have no gifts.
I have a gift.
Oh my God, she brought me to a nice place.
What does she like, guys?
What was her favorite color?
Guys, what's her favorite color?
Is it red?
It has to be red.
It was red.
Okay, alright.
Gotta min-max this.
Okay, if I do this...
Alright, and then, I do the red here.
We min-maxing, guys.
Gotta make sure we have... You know what?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna convert everything to passion now.
I'm gonna optimize.
Oh, I need six sentiments.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We need sentiment, guys.
We're making sure... Oh!
We're doing it!
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, this is... Okay.
Okay, maybe here?
Alright, we got the passion.
We need more sentiment.
We need like...
A couple... We got the sentiment, so let's convert all the broken hearts now.
And then, pink first for combo.
Wait, what?
Really?
Okay.
I'm getting all the pinks.
I'm getting it all in.
Then...
We need the passion, though.
The passion is where...
Pink has a multiplier?
I'm at 26.
I have nine moves left.
Guys, I'm gonna fuck up my day.
Guys!
Guys, I'm...
Guys, this isn't looking so hot.
This is not looking so good, guys.
Okay, we got an extra...
Oh.
This is... Oh.
This is...
Okay.
This is salvageable.
We can fix this.
We...
We got an extra move.
And...
We can fix this.
Go for four in a row?
I had four?
Here?
Okay.
We have seven left.
This is...
This is not looking so good.
This is not looking so good, guys.
This is...
Wait.
No, this is...
Salvageable.
This is...
We're so cucked.
We're so fucked.
This is salvageable.
I can fix this.
We can fix this.
This is fixable.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
We can...
We can fix this.
Guys, we can fix this.
How am I failing this day?
Oh my god.
Why?
Why don't I have unlimited moves?
Ma'am, I thought you liked me.
Don't you like me?
Wait, I got another move.
Guys, I'm back.
I got another move.
I'm back, guys.
It's not over yet.
I got one more in me.
I got one more in me, guys.
It's not over yet.
I still have one more in me.
Oh, I have one more move.
Guys, it's over.
Now it's over.
I need a damn miracle.
This will be the miracle.
No!
I forgot to see the red!
Don't beat yourself up.
This is a bad date.
I don't understand.
I got a new move.
Every time you give a girl a kiss, she'll love it.
I want to send you something to use on dates.
I'm such a nice...
You do it now?
Oh my god.
Now you give me the gift?
Is it only on dates?
Where like...
She'll love me more?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If the streamer reflects the chat, then we're really cooked.
No, guys, guys.
No, it's not that bad.
Guys, it's not that bad.
Like...
We're on the same wavelength, guys.
We're literally like...
On the same wavelength.
So like, I need some...
Okay.
Use an additional hundred.
Talent token matches given...
Guys, which one is the...
Sexuality token matches given additional plus a hundred of...
Alright, we need something.
Product token multiplied to the affection earned from a match by one.
Guys, which one is the best?
Guys.
We need a...
Passion first.
Which one?
We need a...
Is it sexuality?
Oh, this is passion, right?
Okay, passion.
Alright.
Increases...
Level increases six and...
Okay.
We got the passion.
Alright.
We'll come back.
Don't worry.
Okay.
I gotta know what...
Bro, just like...
Just like...
Okay.
I don't know what to do.
I'm...
Okay.
Give her an item and start.
What do I do?
Wait.
What do I...
On to the next girl?
Go to a new girl?
Okay.
Like...
But...
They're both perfect.
Why do I need new girls when I have these two?
When I have these two ladies, why would I need a new girl?
Alright.
Turtle Beach.
Crash and burn.
You said I failed your date and now you want me to be back?
This is fucking hot and cold shit.
Yeah.
Try water.
Her?
Bro, I can barely see an ankle right now.
Am I nobody?
You can't keep all that boob to yourself, hun.
It's not fair to the rest of the world.
The world would be just fine without my...
boobs.
Yeah, but I won't.
Besides, it wasn't cheap.
So, you're stuck with it.
So come on, let's go.
I am not going anywhere in this.
I'm changing back.
Ugh, you are impossible.
Alright.
Enjoying the view?
Oh.
Quick, now's your chance.
Yeah.
Before she does change, just say something.
Anything.
Hey, wait up.
Cheers.
Hi.
Hey.
I'm so embarrassed right now.
My friend made me put this stupid thing on.
You think I'm in?
Sorry.
One second.
Let me go change.
Hey, girl.
Oh, um...
I didn't think I'd get this far.
Um...
Whoa.
Don't worry, I got something.
For the beach, you know.
Oh, what?
That bikini?
I didn't even notice.
What's the worst?
I was hoping you would leave it on.
Your friend has good...
Oh.
Oh, what?
The bikini?
I didn't even notice, girl.
Somehow...
I'm not so sure I believe that.
Oh, you think I'm a liar?
Fuck.
You're all the same.
Okay.
Um...
Oh, so you're not...
Like what?
Adorable?
Too late.
Shut up.
She laughed.
Oh my god.
I'm in their minds.
I know what they want.
I know exactly what they want.
Belly?
She gave me her name, guys.
She...
Anyway, I wanna talk to Bell...
I wanna talk to her.
Sorry, Belly.
No, I'm kidding.
Alright.
Oh.
She's like obviously...
She's obviously like...
Romantic.
So like...
It's easy to know that...
She's gonna say...
Um...
I believe there's one special person out there for everyone.
I feel like...
That's what she wants to hear.
Um...
Because like...
Three?
Really?
Alright, I'm gonna choose three and prove you guys wrong.
You fuckers.
I'm gonna go get water.
You messed it up.
You ruined it.
You fucking...
I knew you guys would ruin it.
I fucking...
I knew...
I knew you guys would ruin this for me.
I fucking...
I knew it.
I knew...
I should've trusted my gut.
I was like...
Obviously, I know what you want.
You were only talking about...
True love.
And you say I had negative reviews?
You fucking ruined it for me.
What the fuck do you mean one guy?
I saw like...
Ten people being like...
Choose three.
Um...
What's your favorite color?
Oh...
The lilac.
Um...
Hey, so like...
What do you do like...
For work?
I mean...
Oh, she's like...
She's all about fucking love!
She's yoga!
Oh my god.
Literally...
Her entire spiel is that she's into yoga.
You think she'll let me go on a date now?
Okay, what does she eat?
Okay, before I take her out...
I'm gonna take you out to a date anyway!
We can eat on a date!
Okay, junk food.
Alright.
Uh...
What is junky enough?
Cotton candy.
Jesus Christ.
French fries.
That's junk food!
Alright.
Here you go.
Get...
Get on.
To the sea.
This is it.
Can't be that bad now.
We're out of the beach area.
Now we're playing tennis.
Oh, this fits!
Woah!
Okay!
Okay.
Um...
What's her favorite color?
Guys...
What's her favorite color, guys?
She likes orange?
Alright, it's orange.
God, where's the...
Okay.
We're level one.
This is fine.
This is...
This is fixable.
We can do this.
Alright, music.
And then...
Do we have any pinks we can do?
No.
This is fine.
Don't worry, guys.
It's not over yet!
150?
Holy shi- Okay.
No, we can...
This is salvageable.
Fuck, okay.
Okay.
We can do this.
There.
A combo.
And then we get an extra move and another combo!
Combo for fucking days!
And then what do I do?
It's not over yet!
You can't say it's over!
It's just begun!
I still have 14 moves left!
I'm literally gaming right now!
Alright.
Let's see.
We got this.
Oh my god!
She loves me.
And then I get an orange as well.
And...
I got too greedy.
I flew too close to the sun.
No!
I thought this was true love.
If this was true love, she wouldn't break up with me like this.
I thought she loved me.
I thought she...
I thought I meant something to her.
Oh my god.
Was it all a lie?
Was everything a fucking lie?
Bro, she played with my heart!
Do you not know what love at first sight meant?
I thought this was love at first sight.
Clearly, she didn't.
She played with my fucking heart.
This was not meant to be.
This is not meant to be.
We would have made it by now.
We actually would have made it.
We would have made it twice.
If I didn't fumble.
Not only did I fumble once, I fumbled two times in a row.
I don't deserve these glasses.
I don't...
I don't deserve these, please.
We won't need the censorship at this rate.
What do you mean?
What do you do to calm down when somebody...
I cry.
Like, right now.
I try to...
But, like, because I know you're into yoga, I'm gonna lie to you.
This is what true love is, guys.
I try to relax and remember that nobody is perfect.
I know my real answer's not gonna make you happy.
I'm gonna lie to you.
Alright, let's see, food.
You like junk food and...
What did you like?
Junk food and...
I'm not gonna even talk to you anymore.
I'm gonna talk to...
I'm gonna talk to Aiko.
Oh my gosh, I...
I don't know, man.
I...
I don't...
I don't know, man.
Can we go on a date?
Oh, bro, she's not into this anymore.
She's...
Guys, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do it, guys.
It's...
Oh, I can feel it.
I...
This is...
This is it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do so well this time, guys.
This is...
Oh, this is it.
I can feel it.
I feel the passion rolling in.
I'm going so fast, nobody will know that...
I'm gonna go so fast.
What's the worst that can happen?
I'm desperate now.
I'm so desperate.
She likes it.
She likes it when I'm desperate too.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We'll do that.
And then...
Alright, I'm now making sure...
That I don't fuck this up.
This is good.
And then we get another one too.
And then...
Another one.
I'm doing it.
It's working.
It's...
She doesn't think I'm pathetic.
She doesn't...
It's...
Guys, it's working.
She doesn't think I'm pathetic, guys.
And even if she does...
Even if she does think I'm pathetic...
She likes that.
So, I'm winning technically.
Okay.
Is there any more reds I could do?
Okay, we're gonna do that.
I have 7 more moves.
This is...
This is possible.
Alright, 116.
I did not fumble it!
I still have 5 more moves!
No.
Maybe I did.
Wait.
Don't say that.
I got bells?
Okay.
And you chose the wrong bell, didn't I?
Guys, I think I chose the wrong bell.
Oh no.
Guys, there's no way.
Guys, I think I chose the wrong bell.
Guys, I...
I chose...
It's not over yet.
Guys, don't say that.
Don't say it's over, guys.
No.
Guys, it's fine.
We got this.
It's still...
It's salvageable.
I...
Why am I not going up?
Okay.
No, now I just have to think.
It's not over, guys.
Don't say that.
Don't say that!
I'm back in!
I'm fucking...
I...
Okay, no.
No.
No, no.
If I do that, this falls down.
No.
If I do that...
This...
Oh, if I do this...
If I...
If I do this...
It'll work.
It's...
I knew it.
I'm so fucking smart.
Holy shit.
I'm so smart.
I did it.
I...
Who said I was gonna fumble that?
I used my brain, chat.
I actually...
Thought about...
I was 20 moves ahead of all of you.
I knew it.
I unlocked her air outfit?
How do I see her outfit?
Settings.
Oh, hey, I can turn this up.
Well, I didn't even realize that.
I guess I'll turn up the BGM.
Wait, I can make it easy?
Wait, I could've made it easy this entire time?
Wait, how do I look at outfits?
I wanna see her outfit.
Is it a good outfit?
Oh.
What's February?
Is this February air?
Is this February?
Hello!
I already...
She asked me all of this.
Did I ask her what her main hobby is?
Oh.
Oh, she's just like me.
But like, not the other stuff, guys.
Just that part.
Just that one thing.
Not the other...
Just that.
Just...
Just that part.
Alright.
Well, I knew that.
I knew she's a teacher.
So, it's like...
It's not...
That's not new to me.
She's not gonna ask me anything?
Oh!
When is your birthday?
So, I can get you a gift for your birthday.
Okay, guys.
I need you guys to remember that for me.
Guys, if you want me to...
If you want me to be successful for her, you gotta know this for me.
Alright, now we got...
Oh, she's sleeping?
What the fuck?
It's the evening!
Anyway, let's talk to her.
Alright.
Guys, I need you to remember that.
If you want me to score it with the prof, you guys need to remember this for me.
Of course.
What was I thinking?
I'm sorry, honey.
Won't happen again.
That's more like it.
How have you been, my darling?
Staying out of trouble?
Well, I try, but...
Trouble has a hard time staying out of trouble.
Oh, she's a bad girl!
So, I take it work is good?
Never better.
Wait, what does she do for work?
What's going on, girl?
Any new mischief to share?
Ugh, where do I start?
Hold that thought.
Have a seat.
I'm gonna go grab you a drink.
I wanna hear all about it.
I'd love to, but...
Yeah, I've got an early day tomorrow.
I just stopped in for a second.
She's no fun!
Don't worry!
That's what I'm here for, girlfriend!
Are you?
Rain check.
You're gonna make her drink by herself?
I'm gonna screw right in after that.
Yeah, yeah.
Get out of here already.
I'm gonna be like...
Hey, baby.
I heard you don't wanna drink alone.
Oh my God, she's a cougar!
I'm in.
Oh, wait!
Okay, okay.
I gotta be super forward.
Okay.
Hey, this is some nice...
Guys, this is too forward.
It's gonna work.
Damn.
That's just surprisingly nice.
Dude, she's acting really aggressive!
10 out of 10.
What can I say?
I'm the Rizly.
Oh my...
It worked.
Oh...
What's...
What are you having?
Oh yeah?
Whoa!
Actually...
Why don't...
You sick?
You're a VTuber.
You can act.
Hey, girl.
Actually...
Why don't we get out of here?
Fuck!
No.
Too forward!
I already talked to her daughter?
Tiffany?!
She has daddy issues?!
Sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can fix it.
Don't worry.
You can cough.
I can't.
Alright.
Long, lame question, but what's your favorite color?
So easy.
Alright.
What does she want from me?
Coward!
First, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you want from me?
Ma'am, what do you want from me, ma'am?
You could...
Okay!
I can handle plenty.
Trouble.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, okay.
Would you like...
Would you like to go on...
A date?
I did it!
Yay!
Oh my god, we're in a hot spring.
We're in hot waters together.
This is what she likes, she's a cougar!
I'm just giving her what she wants.
I'm just giving her what she wants, she's a cougar.
She likes me being pathetic, guys.
I'm just acting.
Chat.
I'm literally... it's acting.
If you guys can't... I'm just acting, guys.
Guys, it was...
It's all just funny, hee-hah-hah acting.
It's not...
Guys, I swear...
It's all...
It's just all acting, guys.
I'm...
I know what I'm doing.
She's a cougar!
She wants me to be like that.
I'm just giving her what she wants.
Oh shit, okay.
Alright, I think convert this...
Oh, I need sensual.
Okay, we'll do that.
And then that.
And then...
Let's see...
And then we'll get the water here.
Oh, 180!
Oh god.
That's beautiful.
185.
Holy shit.
Okay, she...
Alright, okay, so she...
Oh, she...
She wants a lot.
She wants a lot from me.
Four red...
I missed the four!
No!
I was...
I was so shy.
I didn't notice.
It's okay.
It's all fixable.
Everything is fixable, guys.
We can fix all of this.
This is fine.
This is not fine.
This...
This is absolutely not fine at all.
It's over.
I ruined it already.
Oh no.
This is it.
Bro, 885?!
Ma'am...
I'm sorry.
You have so much experience.
I'm just a little guy.
I'm just a little...
I'm sorry.
I'm just a little guy.
Can I have five more moves, ma'am?
Please, can I have five more moves?
I'm just...
I'm trying to do my best, ma'am.
I'm trying so hard.
Oh my god, thank god.
There's a bell.
Okay, four more moves.
This is salvageable.
We can fix this.
Guys, we can always fix this.
We can always fix this.
Is there another bell?
There's no other bell, so I'm just gonna do this.
And then we have another passion.
Here we go.
Okay.
Now I don't...
Oh wait, there's a four.
I love this.
Why did I do that?
I fumbled it.
I didn't realize that doesn't give me anything.
Oh my god.
Honestly,
hon.
Not exactly what I was hoping for.
I'm an experience right now.
I'm like...
I'm so much younger than you.
What did you want from me?
You're supposed to teach me.
I thought I was a cool girl.
She's coked.
She's back.
Airborne ninja.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Well, how I feel about piracy.
Other people on the side.
She can do whatever she wants.
I don't own her.
Is that pathetic enough for you?
Okay.
Let's upgrade this.
Passion, right?
What do we do next guys?
What upgrade do we?
What?
Matara is not impressed.
Blake, thank you for the superchat.
Okay, what do we get?
Sexuality?
Alright, let's do sexuality.
Alright, let's talk.
Tiffany is still asleep.
We can talk to Belly again.
Goodbye.
I'll get better.
I swear, ma'am.
I swear, I'll get better.
Oh shit, am I talking to you again?
Um...
You prefer one season over the other?
Oh, you like... Oh, I don't... Wait, did I already... Oh no, this is the same response.
Gifts?
What does gifts do, anyway?
Look for gifts?
Um, what would Tiffany want?
Dancer, academy, garden, sports, aquarium...
Mistletoe... Mistletoe...
Retro controller, cigarette pack...
Gives you gifts.
Gifts gives date help.
I... Oh, it does?
This one?
The yellow stars are like her likes.
Okay.
Um...
Alright, I'll get you tennis balls.
Hello.
I can't believe you bought this for me.
How nice is that?
You're welcome.
I don't know what else to say, I mean...
Want some balls?
Do you want some balls?
Like, I don't know, like...
I guess.
You have something to say.
We're due for like work.
Oh no, we know that she's a yoga teacher.
This is random, but how tall are you?
Just one inch shy of six feet.
Woah, she's fucking tall.
Giant woman.
Alright, we learned her height.
What else?
We don't need to go on a date anymore.
Oh, Tiffany, you're awake!
I just talked to your mom!
I fucked up, but like...
I'll get into the family somehow.
Hey, I didn't expect to see you here this early.
Alright.
I'm gonna talk to her.
Yeah?
Oh my god, she's so hard to read.
I legitimately don't know what she wants from me.
I don't know what she wants from me.
Oh, thank god, okay.
Oh, thank god.
So she wants a bad boy, but not that bad.
Okay, that's fine.
That's good to know.
She doesn't want a bad boy.
She wants a studious bad boy.
Alright, what do we upgrade?
Luck?
We fucking need it.
Oh my god, we fucking need luck.
Alright, second date!
Let's go!
What's the worst that could happen?
Gosh, she wants hiking.
I'm not talking to her.
Wow!
I love hiking.
Hey guys, have I ever told you how much I love hiking?
You can change my mind so fast.
Hiking's the best, guys.
I'm so passionate about it.
Let's see, 185.
Okay, we can figure it out.
Guys, I need help.
Guys, if you don't want me to fumble, we gotta work together.
Guys, this is a team game now.
This is a team Riz game.
We gotta Riz this together.
19 moves?
Okay, you know I can fuck this up, guys.
Don't say that.
If there's a will, there's a way.
Is there extra hearts anywhere?
Alright, I need it to be green.
There's nothing else to do.
There's only threes.
What do you mean do not do threes?
I don't have any other choice.
Except for this.
Boom, right here.
And then we have this right here.
And then... Bell?
I fucked up, didn't I?
I don't see... Oh, Bell, Bell, Bell.
Nice.
Okay, we got Bell.
And then...
No, that's not it.
Oh, that's it.
That's fucking it.
Okay.
Now we're... I'm gonna use it.
Oh, I need sentiment.
I need three, okay.
We can do this.
And then it's Bear time.
Four.
Nice, we got four.
See, I didn't fuck it up.
I didn't... I didn't fuck it up.
Wait, I fucked it up?
No!
I was so confident, too.
I was like, look guys, I didn't fuck it up.
How could I?
How could I fuck this up, guys?
There's no way.
Salvageable.
Isn't that four hearts?
Isn't that four?
Four?
Oh, I fucked it up again?
It's okay.
Because I have four hearts right here.
I told you guys.
There's no more fires here.
What do I do?
I have five?
Where's the number five?
Blue and green?
Where's blue and green?
There's four...
Guys, guys, don't do this to me, guys.
Guys.
Guys, I... Guys, you gotta... We gotta work this together, guys.
We have nine moves, we have to do this together.
Blue, bottom, right.
That's not four, that's three.
Guys, do you know how to count?
Guys, that's three!
That's three.
Blue on the... Here?
Like this?
How is that a combo?
Like this.
I swear, I'm gonna do it.
Okay.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
I'm so smart.
Wow.
Wait, it's... Wait, it's possible.
Oh my god, I'm so smart.
I'm so smart, I'm gonna get in the family somehow.
Guys, we're gonna make it into the family.
We're gonna make it to the family.
It's possible.
Okay.
Okay, what do we do?
Bottom, alright.
But it's not gonna increase anything.
We need points, guys.
Welcome to the family.
Guys, this...
Why you gotta make it weird?
Why?
It's not weird!
How is it weird?
I'm just... I'm just trying to play the game.
I'm just... I'm just trying to fucking... I'm trying to do my best here.
I'm trying so hard.
Now bell?
Where?
There's no bell anywhere.
What do you mean bell?
I don't see no...
Oh.
Guys, I saw the bell.
Oh my god, wait, it's possible.
Wait, okay.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
Four hearts.
We don't need no hearts!
There's a four?
How is there four?
I'm counting!
That's a three?
Four light blue at the bottom?
That's...
Oh, thank god.
Oh my god, it's possible.
Oh my god, this is a team game, guys.
We did it.
I did it.
We're in.
I fucking love hiking.
I...
I told you, I can riz, guys.
Guys, I fucking love hiking so much, guys.
Alright.
Wow!
I love hiking so much, guys.
Wow.
Hiking is my favorite activity.
If it helps get some more date gifts, go to the store and look for gifts with a heart beside them.
And give it to them, whatever girl you're seeing at the moment.
They'll show up in your invite as presents.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, alright.
What's your opinion on people who smoke?
I feel like you don't like smokers.
Oh, thank god.
You seem like a girl that doesn't smoke.
Okay, I don't understand her.
Does she like a bad boy or not?
I don't understand.
What does she want?
So, exactly how old are you?
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
And how old am I playing as?
Okay, let's find somebody else.
Oh, it's morning time.
Okay.
I have to be...
I have to be young because, like, she's a cougar.
And I'm also... There's two cougars.
So, like, I have to be young.
I just don't go to university, I guess.
I might be a dropout.
New girl!
But we have four girls!
There's so many girls!
I don't know if I can handle so many girls, guys.
There's so many girls.
I love this picture.
This is a...
Oh, Tiffany.
Alright, let's gotcha.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna be like, alright guys, it's gotcha time.
Okay.
Alright, thank God.
But we're fine.
Hey!
That's me!
It's me.
That's me.
Alright, we'll buy Yo-Yo.
She likes Yo-Yo.
Can I just give this to her?
Yay!
She's gonna get me a gift!
Okay.
Wait, I'm so rich!
I might as well get her.
I'll get a pencil.
That's cheap.
I'm tolerable, guys!
I'm in.
I'm so in.
Did I ask her how old is she?
Did I ask her what her favorite color is?
Oh, no, no, no.
I'm just so interested in you.
I'm so interested.
You're... I'm literally at your campus.
I'm not... Wait, no.
She thinks I'm stupid, so I'll be like...
Oh my gosh.
Are you a university professor?
What do you mean?
I'm literally at your workplace.
I'm at the university.
There's only one university here.
There's only one.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
This is it.
We're so... We can't... We're not gonna fumble this time.
I forgot to get the gift, but this is it.
Guys, guys.
I forgot.
I forgot to get the gift, but this is it.
This is it.
Oh my god!
This is fine.
We can do this.
Guys, we can do this together.
This is a team game, guys.
Guys, it's not over.
Why is she... How did it get to 220?
How did we get here?
How did we get to 220?
I don't understand.
How did we get there?
It's over.
We just started.
How can it be over?
More red?
Where the fuck... 1, 2, 3, 4...
Where is the 4 at?
Where do you see 4?
Where do you see a 4?
Am I stupid?
Don't answer that.
Where do you see the 4?
I'm so confused.
Oh, set up 4.
Where do you see 4 green?
How?
What?
I don't know where you see...
I'm looking at the same screen as you guys.
I'm looking at... I'm literally looking at the same game.
Orange swap with green.
There's so many oranges.
This?
Or this?
Wait, no.
There's a 5... How are you reading 20 moves?
How do you... How do you read 20 moves ahead?
This.
Okay.
No!
Alright, now we're freestyling.
Okay, please.
What do you mean no?
I'm fucking... I'm trying to...
I was like this and one... I got one guy.
I literally saw a yes.
I swapped this over.
I can't let you ruin it.
I don't know what you want from me.
I'm not... I have my throwing.
I'm doing the best I could.
I'm trying to play.
It's over before it begun.
I don't understand.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna fucking do it.
I'm fucking... Oh my god.
I...
Don't... Please stop.
Stop.
Please, I'm overthinking now.
Four reds.
I don't see this.
The four red fuckers you're talking about.
I don't see.
I'm blind.
I'm putting...
No.
The reds said...
Stop!
I don't know!
I love my beach.
One of my anime games.
Rainbow, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like this?
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna fucking do it.
That's too late.
Now there's no more four reds.
Now you'll never get four reds.
I'm gonna... I'm freestyle.
I'm freestyling.
You can't stop me.
I'm gonna fucking freestyle now.
Oh, you can't stop me.
That's right.
I'm freestyle.
I'm going wild now.
That's right.
You can't stop me.
I'm freestyling this.
That's...
It's over.
She's over the edge, guys.
It's over now.
It's so...
No, let her cook.
No!
That's right.
I'm going in with no idea what I'm doing now.
That's fucking right.
No one will know what I'm doing.
That's right.
Head empty time.
Alright, now I don't know.
Now I'm a little stuck now.
No way.
No.
Alright, let's... Now I don't know anymore.
This freestyle has gone out of control.
This freestyle...
The freestyle has gone out of control, guys.
I'm at a point where I don't know what I'm doing no more.
I can't fuck me over, right?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Now I'm definitely lost.
Now...
Now we have... Now we have a problem.
Now we have a problem.
Oh wait, unless...
Yeah.
Yeah!
Okay.
Okay, now what?
Wait, I'm cooking.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute, I'm actually doing something.
Wait.
How did we get here?
Now I don't know what to do anymore.
Blue in the corner?
That doesn't get me anything.
The bottom right bell?
Okay,
please.
Oh!
Absolute cinema.
Freestyle.
That's right!
The freestyle worked!
I told you!
I fucking...
Nobody believed me!
Nobody believed me.
I told you the freestyle.
An empty strack actually worked.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This stream is making me fall into alcoholism.
Doki, how did this work?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ace, thank you for the super chat.
I like how people are super chatting me about how to play the game.
By the way, you buy the girl's drinks, they give you more points when you talk to them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was just...
That was just that easy, guys.
What can I say?
I'm just naturally goaded.
I'm just...
I'm just a natural gamer.
Alright, sake.
Where's sake?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, here.
Oh my God, let's talk to her.
Hello.
When is your birthday?
Oh, fuck you!
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
You want some gifts?
I'm so sorry.
There's so many...
Guys, there's so many girls.
Oh my God, okay.
That's fine.
Oh, fuck.
I can't handle all these women!
I have...
You guys wanted me to talk to a fifth woman, and I couldn't even...
I didn't remember her birthday.
There's just...
There's too many women.
There's just too many women.
Four is so many.
Guys, four is so many.
You don't understand.
There's...
There's four...
There's four women.
There's so many women.
There's so many...
You want to be a girl in a game?
You can change it.
Bonkers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I don't know...
Guys, I...
I don't know if...
I can add more women...
in my repertoire.
Guys, there's...
I'm getting a little overwhelmed.
She gave me high heels?
Okay.
In the future, all Riz will be randomly generated.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Guys, no, there's...
Guys, I don't know if I can handle more.
I...
I don't know if I can get a fifth one into this equation.
Guys.
There's...
There's eleven?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Skill issue.
Oh, it's night time?
So I have learned from that is that Doki is a freestyle genius and that Doki would not be able to handle a harem.
Guys, I...
Guys, two was already too much.
Like...
Okay.
Wait, we have to equip it?
I already had it equipped.
How do I equip it?
Guys, how do I equip gifts?
How do I...
Oh, move it down?
What?
Drag it to the bottom?
Like here?
It won't let me equip it.
I'm dragging it.
I'm so...
Okay.
Alright, here we...
Alright, we did it, boys.
We learned how to use a phone.
Guys.
We did the bare minimum.
We learned how to use...
Guys, it's over.
We learned how to use a fucking phone.
Okay.
Guys, I'm...
Alright, what should we upgrade?
Guys, what's the best next upgrade?
Guys, what do we get?
Passion?
Passion.
Okay, we got passion.
Next up is a snow globe, apparently.
Wait, I have a message?
Well, fuck me.
I finally won something at the casino.
Great, now maybe I can put a tiny dent in my massive debt.
Alright, I'm ready.
Okay, I'm ready.
Okay, now you're scaring me.
Oh, it's safe?
Alright, let's go gambling, guys.
Guys.
Let's go gambling!
Oh, thank God.
This is the riskiest gamble.
Every photo is a new gamble.
Every fucking photo.
Okay, we're good.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
What did I ask her?
Guys, I...
What's your favorite?
Oh, thank God.
There's so many women I talked to already.
Okay, date time!
Date time!
Let's go!
Look, none of them asked me to go steady.
None of them asked me to go steady, so it's fine.
Oh!
260?!
Okay.
Matches made that is just other than the one you selected.
Increase the set amount of broken hearts that fall by for the remainder of the date.
Consume a select row of tokens.
Broken hearts...
Green?!
Guys, I don't know if I can freestyle this, guys.
Guys, I...
Guys, we have a little problem here.
Freestyling for 260 is...
Okay.
Alright.
We're gonna freestyle.
We're gonna...
Okay.
We got the bell.
Alright.
How did I fuck it up already?!
I...
I'm getting that heart.
Fuck it.
How did I already fuck it up?!
That's it.
That's it!
We're going!
No more playing around.
No.
It's over.
It only took one guy to make me go nuclear.
It's already over.
It's...
Why did she...
It's so...
It's...
It's not going so well, guys.
I already...
I already blew up.
Alright.
We're at plus four.
Here we go.
Okay.
This is not good.
This...
This is a little awkward now.
It's okay.
I get another bell.
That's fine.
That's okay.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we're gonna get more sentiment.
Let's grab some sentiment and then let's grab an extra turn so it's like I didn't make a mistake there.
And then...
Okay.
Let's use an item.
Guys, are any of these items good?
Guys?
Guys, please.
This is an SOS right now.
Guys.
Are any of these good?
Like, five red?
Where?
I can't count to five?
Okay.
You will not lose any moves until a match is made as of a different than the one you selected.
Let's do it.
So how do I do this?
Okay.
Let's get the orange.
Get the hearts?
Really?
Do we get red or...
Red?
Red!
What did I do?
Wait.
I clicked red.
What did I do?
Oh, do your reds now!
Oh!
Okay.
I'll do this first.
And then...
I do this.
Which red do I do?
Right or bottom?
Right or bottom, guys?
Guys, okay, now we used it all up.
Alright, that's fine.
Okay, now we're fucked.
Now!
This is over.
Now we can say it's over.
Guys, who let me freestyle?
Who do we blame for this?
Because it's not my fault.
Who do we blame...
For making me have a breakdown?
We gotta blame somebody.
If that one person didn't make me have a breakdown there...
This would've been salvageable.
Green from the left?
How the fuck were you counting five?
That's three.
One, two, three.
This?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Alright.
It's working?
Guys, I blame the guy that made me have a breakdown there.
I blame whoever made me have a breakdown.
That's on you.
Okay, we could've saved this.
No, blame yourself.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we have a move.
We can still fix this.
This is like...
Guys, this is so scary.
Oh, shit, no!
Wait, no!
That was...
That could've...
We could've fucked up.
We almost fucked it up.
But it's okay, we didn't.
And that's all that matters.
We salvaged it.
There's another orange here.
Five hearts?
Oh, shit, you're right.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now we're maxed.
Alright.
Let's figure this out, guys, as a team.
But we do tier.
It's not gonna hit 260, though.
Five tiers doesn't...
Does five tiers build it up?
Chat?
Does that give us points?
We don't need sentiment, guys.
I need love.
We don't need sentiment.
We need love.
C10 to C18.
Oh my fucking god.
Guys, but what about love?
Love is important.
Okay.
How do we do this?
We got this.
Select our target.
Okay.
Clearly, we want the...
Okay, guys, we need to figure this out.
Five green?
Where?
What is love?
Where's five?
Where do you see five?
I see two.
Green into a big combo.
Where?
L-shaped green.
Here?
Oh shit, I see it.
No, if we do that, we get the hearts.
Guys, no, that's a bad.
That's a bad.
If we do this, these fall down, and then we get all the negative hearts.
Wait, top row?
The second row?
If we do this...
How?
They don't?
They don't.
No, they do.
No, they don't.
I can't see stuff.
Okay.
You're right, I am blind.
I'm blind, guys.
I am actually blind.
I might as well be... Oh my god, that was so close.
That was actually so close.
I almost could have fucked that up right there.
Holy shit.
I almost did it.
I almost autopiloted that.
I...
I actually...
I almost just go...
Right here.
Okay.
That was...
That was almost an autopilot mistake there, but we fucking powered through.
Oh my god.
Fucking...
Easiest game of my fucking life.
Easy.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
Are you for real?
Guys, she said I'm perfect.
Guys.
She said I'm perfect.
My fake personality that I crafted just for her.
It's perfect.
I'm basically like Ratatouille-ing this.
Chat is like the fucking rat on my head at the moment.
Oh shit.
Do you think she'll be okay if I ask her cup size?
Oh, thank god.
Thank... This is true love.
Holy shit, are they all D cups?
Jesus Christ.
Are you all D cups?
Oh, I should get her alcohol.
Wait, what's...
Is she like wine?
Oh, of course, because you're a classy girl.
Guys, I'm not meeting another girl.
I can't.
I...
I could barely survive.
You like wine.
You don't want wine?
Yoga instructor.
That's the only thing I remember from these women.
What they do for a living.
I'm sorry.
I can't remember.
I legitimately...
I legitimately can't remember like...
What...
What their favorite colors are.
I can't even remember like...
Other people's favorite colors.
I can't, guys.
I cannot do five girls.
Guys, you don't understand.
Five is just too many.
It's just...
It's just too many.
Oh, my God.
My bestie took this picture in class when I wasn't looking.
Uh-oh.
Panty shot.
So embarrassing.
But let me send it to you.
Okay.
I'm gonna predict where the panty shot is.
Right here.
Okay.
This is like...
We were all...
We were close.
We were so close.
Let's just...
There we go.
Okay.
All right.
Wow.
That was...
What a good friend.
That's all I could say.
What a great friend.
Okay.
All right.
From...
From the other girl.
It's so nice out this morning.
We should go for a walk in the park one of these days.
I'd love to have company.
Oh, my God.
What a nice girl.
What a nice demure girl.
Five is just too many.
One is too many for you, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Blondie, thank you for the super chat.
Never thought watching someone else go on a date would be more successful than actually going on a date.
You just be like...
All right, let's do the stuff that...
Doki, to be successful on your date, do the things that Doki...
Do the things that Doki doesn't do.
So everything she does now...
is basically the wrong thing.
Pop quiz.
How big are my boobs?
As if I even have to ask.
D -size!
Because I only asked, like, two people.
Well, I'll be damned.
You got it.
Oh, my God.
I've only asked two people.
Let's see.
Longest relationship you've ever had?
Oh, shit.
My longest probably a year and some change.
I'm lucky I can keep it together for two weeks.
Several years.
Oh, my gosh.
Is she looking for something serious?
I can't tell.
Whoa.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I remember two things.
Cup sizes.
And what they do for a living.
Probably a year.
You think a year?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I couldn't tell what she wanted from me.
I legitimately...
I couldn't tell, guys.
Like...
Should I buy her more gifts?
If I buy her more gifts, does she give me more stuff, chat?
Guys, does she give me more stuff if I buy her more gifts?
She doesn't like wine.
She likes sake.
Yeah?
Okay.
We know what to do.
I'm gonna get her some drinks.
And then buy her a puzzle cube.
Alright.
What did you give me?
Consumes all talent tokens.
Oh, that's good!
Alright.
It's time.
Okay.
We can do this, chat.
Remember...
The moment we get one girl...
Like...
We got this, guys.
We just need one...
One woman...
To think we're cool.
That's...
We just need...
That's all we need, like...
We just need one of them...
To think we're cool.
It...
It can't be that difficult, right?
It can't...
We just need to think we're pretty cool.
Alright.
That's good.
We're not dead!
This is doable.
This is so...
It's so doable, guys.
Just keep believing!
Okay.
That's fine.
We fixed it.
That's...
That's fine.
We salvaged it.
We...
Guys, I...
I freestyled too hard.
I freestyled...
I...
There's no way...
Guys, it's okay, like...
Sometimes I get a little too excited.
I...
I just got...
I got too excited, okay?
Like, it's...
I'm working on it.
I just...
It was...
Woah.
Not bad.
Same green full left?
What?
Oh!
Okay, we need more sentiment.
I realized we were not working on sentiment.
It should be fine.
Uh...
And then we get an extra move here, so that's good.
Alright.
And then we get more hearts, which is also good.
Alright, guys.
Get those broken hearts out of here.
And then red.
Okay.
Do we do red or pink first, guys?
Hearts, do we do red or heart?
What do we do?
Pink, four hearts?
Where's the four?
Guys, I can't count.
Where the fuck do you see four hearts?
Oh!
Oh, thank God.
I'm not...
I'm not that blind.
Alright.
We're okay.
No!
We're not okay anymore.
We have a bell.
Nice.
We do this first.
We'll do this.
And then we'll do this.
And then we do this.
And then...
You know what?
And then after that, I can do whatever the fuck I want.
And then after that...
I can freestyle.
Freestyle.
Let's go.
Easy.
Fucking easy.
Really?
Look at that.
Didn't fumble.
I'm actually getting better at rizzing.
This is actually like a character art, guys.
I'm improving.
Whoa.
I love swimming.
Oh, I got a new message.
You're so close.
Once your relationship with a girl is at four or more hearts, there's a chance you can pull her home after the next date?
Take her out at night, though?
That's...
the only way.
But we haven't...
Wait, but...
Do you think she's gonna hold hands with me?
Guys?
Am I...
Am I gonna hold hands with her?
What?
Oh shit.
I only have...
Guys.
Guys, we can't...
We can't be honest right now.
Guys.
Oh shit.
I don't know.
She wants me to be honest.
Oh, thank God.
We're okay.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
I don't know.
My entire personality in this date right now is manufactured so I can see...
so we can hold hands.
So...
Like...
My entire personality is manufactured right now because I want to hold her hand.
Pre-marital eye contact incoming.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Um...
What do we want, guys?
What's the best upgrade next?
See what luck?
I don't have enough for that.
I don't know what to get.
Passion?
Red or green?
Flirtation?
Do we have flirtation or sexuality?
Oh, flirt for Tiffany?
Who's Tiffany?
Oh, sorry.
Guys, I told you.
There's too many girls.
I already forgot their names.
I just know what they look like now.
I'm at a point where my brain has deleted what their names are and just know what they look like.
There's too many to keep track of, chat.
That was me.
There's too many to keep track.
I can't do a fifth woman.
Alright.
We gotta talk to her at...
We gotta talk to her at night.
Anton!
Thank you.
If you give her the right gift, you get enough points to afford a 2800?
Oh, I got a message from Aiko.
Hey, handsome.
I really enjoyed our...
Okay.
Let's figure out...
Let's decide... Let's play a game, chat.
Guys, let's play a game.
Where do we need a sensor?
I think it's...
Get the sensor image!
Okay.
We're not gonna play that game.
We're not...
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH Right here.
Okay.
So...
Whoa.
Okay.
So...
You can sort of...
What?
Okay.
Alright.
This is beyond hand-holding, chat.
Guys.
This...
This is beyond hand-holding.
Guys.
I...
This is not hand-holding, guys.
This is...
This is not...
Guys!
I thought we were gonna...
I thought we were gonna hold hands.
I know.
Well,
we're at the beach.
Oh.
Sorry, I don't know.
I thought this...
We're literally on the beach, though, Tiffany.
Tiffany, we're at the beach.
I thought you wanted me to answer the beach answer.
We're at the beach.
We'll see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki's laugh made that one more.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tati, thank you for the super chat.
I left the room for like two minutes.
What happened?
Nothing happened.
No, you didn't miss out on anything.
Disrespectful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My earphone jack disconnected in my bank...
In my bank.
...at work, and you screamed so loud at the right time...
...that everyone is looking at me.
We just held hands, you know?
We just held hands.
That's...
Yeah.
Hand-holding.
Okay.
Okay, $3.50.
Alright, you like to...
Oh my god, I've lost track of what people like.
Guys, I've lost track of what they all like.
Guys, I can't tell no more.
Green!
Okay, green.
I'm serious when I say I don't know anymore what they like.
I don't know anymore.
Okay, but now I know they like green.
There's just so many of them that...
I just...
I can't tell anymore.
There's too many.
There's just way too many to keep track.
Yeah, I don't have any pink at the moment, so I'm just gonna...
I'm just freestyling again.
It's our favorite thing to do, chat.
It's our favorite thing to do.
Oh my god!
We're so fucked.
We need $3.50.
We need $3.50, guys.
Alright, there we go.
What do we do here?
It's so over?
No, it's fine.
Don't say that.
It's never over, guys.
It's...
Guys, don't say that.
Guys, it's never over.
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
It's never over, guys.
Don't be silly.
Don't be silly, guys.
It's not over.
There's still hope.
I can set up five red?
I can do that?
Red bottom, the top four red?
That's not four.
That's three.
That's not...
Match blue in the bottom middle?
Music notes?
Here?
No.
Okay.
There's a right blue?
Here.
This one.
I need everybody to know if I'm...
This one?
Yes.
Alright.
Oh shit!
Oh shit, we're so smart.
I'm so smart.
Alright.
Alright, now I'm lost.
We're not back.
We have 350, guys.
We're like so far from back, guys.
Guys, we're so far from back.
I don't know where you think the back part's at, but we're not there.
We are most definitely not there.
Okay.
We can maybe...
Consume all talents.
Okay, if we get five, we might be able to do this and then be back again.
We're gonna do that.
And then we're gonna get enough talents here.
And then...
If I do this and I consume all the green, will it work?
Will we get all the bonus points for green?
Guys, there's 11 moves and we're at 94.
Okay, I'm gonna consume this.
Guys, if I do this...
Oh, talent is blue?
Your talent is blue?
I thought it was green!
Oh, this consumes blue!
Oh my God, I'm so fucking stupid.
Oh my...
I didn't realize it meant it consumes this color.
I'm so stupid.
Okay, okay.
Okay, we still got this.
We still got this.
I was thinking...
I don't know what I was thinking.
I know, I know.
Alright, we're still gonna use it though.
Alright.
Nice.
Then we get an extra here.
And then we can get red here.
Yes.
Alright.
350.
Okay.
Alright.
Now, this is...
This is very risky.
We can get...
One more and do another talent.
Yeah.
And then consume a selected...
Alright, should we do vintage platform?
Or hairbrush?
Guys, which one?
Left heart?
We should do left heart?
Left bell?
Guys, I...
Where are you seeing this bell?
Move the bell to the left side?
Guys, where the fuck are you seeing this bell?
Bell left corner?
The fuck you want me to move this to?
Like, there's nowhere to move this.
Bottom left to up?
Are you blind?
Am I blind?
There are two directions.
Yes.
Oh shit.
We figured it out.
We did it, everybody.
We fucking did it.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, we can get four here.
Is this worth it?
Four reds, this could be worth it, right?
This should be worth it.
Okay, we have a hundred.
Okay, do we do platform shoes or hairbrush, guys?
Brush?
But where do we do it at?
Guys, where do we do it at?
I say brush?
Brush your shoes.
Brush?
I'm doing it.
Alright, what row?
Guys, this is it.
We have five turns.
Do something with Tiffany.
I did not mean the word like that.
But we have two moves to figure this out together.
This or this?
Which second row?
Which way are you counting?
One, two or one, two?
Yeah?
Here.
Right here.
Your final answer.
I'm gonna do it.
It's gonna get done.
Alright.
Yes.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Okay.
We put green here.
Or...
Alright.
We can get another three and get platform shoes.
Do we do it?
Is it worth it, guys?
If we do three and get platform shoes...
Is it worth it?
Alright.
No?
Green star at the top?
Okay, we'll get the green star first.
We'll do this first, actually.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, guys, wait.
Wait, this is possible.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Is it worth it?
Do we do it?
Do we get... Do we get the shoes?
If we get the shoes, we have three turns.
Alright.
We're not choosing hearts!
There's no...
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, three turns and a drink.
Which color?
What do we do?
Red?
Oh God, okay.
Okay, we go up.
Which way?
Orange?
And we move here.
There's only one thing we can do in orange.
Orange?
Here?
But we move here.
Okay, I'm clicking it.
I'm gonna click it.
And I move this.
Which we move first, actually.
Is that the only thing we can move?
Which one?
This one or this one?
This one.
This one?
Which one?
There's so many oranges, I'm freaking out!
This one.
And then this.
Yeah?
I'm gonna do it!
I'm gonna fucking do it!
Oh my God, this three moves bullshit is gonna fucking kill me.
I'm gonna go fucking crazy.
I'm...
I'm gonna go crazy.
I'm gonna...
Oh wait, orange again.
Wait, I can do another orange.
Wait, which one?
Okay.
No?
Why no?
Yeah?
Okay.
And another one.
Yeah, but I have... Don't I have the unlimited moves right now?
I have unlimited moves though!
Wait, no!
What happened to my unlimited orange moves?
Okay.
Orange
moves!
Oh my God, we did it!
Oh, we did it!
My God, I'm the coolest guy she knows.
We're ratatouille-ing this.
I'm bringing you guys along.
We're ratatouille-ing you along on this date.
Oh my God.
Oh shit.
How much do you weigh?
Nice.
Good for you.
Um...
Can I bring some people to our date?
Like, don't freak out, okay?
If you hear things underneath my hat...
Don't freak out, you're just crazy.
How tall are you?
Alright.
We learned her.
It's still the afternoon.
Okay, and then she's tired of talking to me.
Alright, Jessie!
Jessie!
Hello, Jessie.
Is it nighttime yet?
Oh, it's still evening.
Goddammit.
Oh, she's doing fitness.
Hey!
Oh, me?
Thanks, it does feel a little warm here.
Alright.
What does she want?
Martini.
Maybe she'll want a drink while she's working out.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Like, you do you, girl.
Alright, nice.
Alright, time to talk.
Doesn't she smoke?
I think you're kinda sexy.
Oh, yeah?
You smoke?
Oh, me too.
I can totally smoke.
Not my first time.
Hey, I took this for you, ya pervert!
Hope it came out alright.
It was...
Okay.
Guys, I'm a little nervous, guys.
I hope nothing shows at the fucking corners.
Okay.
I don't even know how to censor this.
I...
I don't even...
God.
Holy shit.
Oh my God.
Guys, I...
I don't know how to...
I don't...
I don't know how to censor this, guys.
Guys, this is a problem.
I need to use two censors.
This is such a problem.
This is...
This is a huge problem.
Oh my God, I don't even know if I'm safe.
I don't even...
Oh God, okay.
Alright.
This is gonna...
This is actually gonna be really bad.
Oh, God.
This is not...
This is...
Okay, great.
You...
You can sort of tell where this is...
Where...
What...
What's going on?
Guys, do you think she likes me?
Alright, guys.
Guys, do you think she likes me, guys?
She's...
She's just...
She's just really enjoying TV, chat.
Like...
She's...
I wonder what she's watching right now.
I wonder...
I wonder what she's watching at the moment, chat.
Could be anything.
I'm the pervert!
She sent this to me and I'm the pervert!
Okay.
Alright.
What a wild ride there.
Guys, I don't even want to talk to these ladies anymore.
I just...
I'm just gonna wait until this date night.
I'm just...
I'm sorry.
I don't...
Oh my God.
Yes!
You wanna...
You wanna go on a...
On a...
Date...
Wait, how do I...
How do I...
Go on this date?
Wait, I got denied?
How do I get denied?
She doesn't even want to go on a date with me.
Wait, what do I get, chat?
Guys, what do I...
At the wizard tomorrow?
What?
Guys, what do I get, guys?
Guys, I need to know.
Pink?
Passion?
Passion.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm skipping this.
I...
I'm fucking rotating this a day.
I can't.
I'm...
I...
Oh my God.
There's...
Other than...
Alright, morning time.
Okay, we just gotta wait until it's night time.
Alright.
You're gonna take too long.
I...
Alright, what size?
Oh, you're also the D cup.
I only know two bust sizes.
And they're both D.
I can do Tiffany now?
Okay.
Hey, Tiffany.
Wow, I really like the gym.
Okay.
Alright.
Hey, Tiffany.
I love hiking.
Okay.
Let's do this again.
Oh, thank God, bro.
I feel like I'm fucking gambling every time.
Oh, thank God.
God.
This feels like a goddamn gamble.
Okay.
Wanna go on a...
You wanna...
You have a gift?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Oh, I have two!
Consume a select broken tokens plus one move for every four of a kind?
Wait, that's great.
And I guess we'll take away the perfume, right?
And we'll do this.
Eyelash curler.
Okay.
Oh, don't date until nighttime?
I'm just...
I'm gonna travel.
I'm traveling.
Alright, guys.
Who would've thought it was gonna be the teach...
I'm not gonna talk to her.
I can barely remember all the women.
You wanna drink?
Oh, you might as well.
Let's just talk.
You wanna...
Oh, I got a good one?
Okay.
Fuck.
You know what?
You're not even endgame.
What's my fav...
Oh, it's Lilac.
I remember.
It doesn't matter what I say to her.
I...
Oh, man.
That's crazy.
It doesn't matter.
She's not endgame.
Hmm?
Alright.
You're perfect.
But what if...
Oh, my God.
What do you want from me?
Okay, go buy your own food.
I'm fucking...
I need it.
Alright, guys.
Okay.
Alright, who's endgame, guys?
Actually, no.
Because I could fuck up.
Oh, God.
I can't fuck this up.
Okay.
You know, Aiko was there for me in the beginning.
She was the easiest to read, guys.
Aiko...
Aiko knew what I wanted.
And I knew what Aiko wanted.
It's time.
Alright.
It's...
Oh, fuck.
It's time.
Okay.
No.
Fuck.
Alright.
Okay.
Wow.
Wait, get her...
Get her a drink?
Okay, I'll get her a drink.
Where's the sake?
I know she likes sake.
Wait, is there no sake anymore?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Why do I need to get her a drink?
Where's the sake?
No.
Wait, why?
Why do I need a drink?
Give her...
Why do I need to give...
Oh, it makes it easier?
Does it have to be her favorite drink?
Wait, I got...
Wait, it makes the game easier?
Oh my god.
You say...
Why you tell me that now?
Fucking...
Okay.
This feels...
Here's beer.
It was cheap.
Alright.
Okay.
Is it...
Are we ready?
Are we...
Are we good to go?
And food?
Alright.
What's your favorite?
You know what?
I feel like I can spoil you today.
Alright.
One more.
One more to go.
You know what?
Oh, tomato.
Alright.
Tomatoes is her favorite.
Alright!
Here we go!
Talk?
Talk with her?
Do we talk with her or do we go on a date?
It was destiny.
Her favorite food is tomatoes.
Censor?!
Wait, why?
Oh, Port Bar and Lounge.
Let's go.
What's she gonna wear?
Yeah!
Alright.
Okay.
Heart.
Yeah, it's not that bad.
Alright.
Okay.
Yo, can you preemptively censor the right side of the screen if you succeed on this date?
She will.
Woah.
Alright.
Delete.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
Woah.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wow.
Wowee.
Wowza.
Hahaha.
Alright, I'll do reds here.
Um...
And then four reds here.
Alright.
Wowee.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Wow, wow.
Wait, no?
Why?
Okay.
I think I'm doing okay.
Hahaha.
I think...
I'm getting flustered right now.
Okay.
I think things are going quite dandy.
Um...
Wowee.
Zowie mama.
Not okay.
I'm getting flustered right now.
I'm getting a little flustered.
I'm getting a little...
Not bad.
Oh my god, I'm doing it.
I don't know how.
Alright.
And then...
You know what?
Convert.
Alright, here we go.
I was getting a little scared, guys.
I was getting very scared.
Hahaha.
Orange.
Uh...
Which one?
There's so many or- Oh wait, I can do reds here though.
Yeah!
And then I can do another red here.
Yay!
Julia, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're gonna need this for when...
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
It can't be that bad.
What's the worst that could happen?
What's the...
What's...
Oh man, what's the worst that could happen?
What's the...
Whoa, what?
Four hearts?
Where the fuck you seeing this four hearts?
That's three.
That's two.
Guys, you gotta talk to me in battleship terms.
You gotta...
Hahaha.
This gotta be done in battleships.
Oh, there's four.
Alright.
That's fine.
Do this.
And then...
We do orange.
E4 and a G4.
Alright, guys.
We gotta figure this out now together.
Four blue.
Oh, there's four blue right here.
And then there's...
Four red.
Four...
Wait, four red.
This is so risky.
Oh my God, that was so risky.
Oh, that's so risky.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, we're almost there.
Why?
We're not close yet.
We should be fine.
Right?
Guys, we should be fine.
We're not there yet.
This is nothing bad's gonna happen yet, guys.
And then we get an extra turn.
Like, look, she's...
She's okay.
Oh, my bedroom.
I think that's where they are.
Alright, let's...
Let's go gambling.
That was not where they are.
That's fine.
We got it.
Okay.
It's...
It's okay.
It was almost...
We...
The bottle won't move!
Okay, alright.
Let's see.
No, it won't.
It doesn't move that much.
Okay, you're right.
We might need one more.
Let's just...
Okay.
Oh my God.
I didn't think this game would go so long.
But here we go.
Alright.
Go ahead.
I could do whatever the fuck I...
Let me turn this.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I'll make my own sound.
She's like going...
Wow, wow, wow, wow!
Woo!
Yeah!
Wow!
Woo!
Let's go!
Wowee!
Yoohoohoo!
I know.
Yeah!
Wowee!
Yippee!
Yeah!
Yippee-ki-yay!
Oh my God!
Yeah!
Oh my God.
How fast do I have to go?
Jesus!
I
went too fast.
I went too fast.
I did not realize.
I...
I didn't know.
I didn't know she'd take her clothes off.
I...
I didn't know her clothes would be off.
Guys...
We're gonna lock that in.
Okay, and then...
We're still safe here.
We're still...
We're still a little safe here.
I...
I didn't know.
I didn't...
Oh my God, this is so not safe.
This is so not safe, guys.
This is so not safe.
This is...
This...
This is not safe at all.
Guys, you guys don't wanna play but you won't.
Okay, I feel a little more confident.
I...
There we go.
We did it.
Wow!
We're just playing Bejeweled now.
Like, it's Bejeweled time.
It's Bejeweled time.
Okay.
We're just...
We're just having a fun Bejeweled hours.
Bejeweled...
Oh my God, I can't.
I can't.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, I...
I can't.
Guys, this will be fun.
Everything will be fun.
You guys...
Oh my God, I can't.
Wowee!
I'm not fast enough.
I can't.
I'm sorry, ma'am.
I'm just not fast enough.
I'm sorry.
I can't be as fast as you want me.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I'm done.
Oh my God.
Slow and steady wins the race.
I'm panicking.
I don't...
Oh my God, I lost all the progress.
I'm so slow.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, ma'am.
Can you please teach me?
I'm so sorry.
I'm just...
Wowee.
I just need a B.
Oh my God.
Please hold my hand.
I'm so embarrassed.
Oh shit.
She's making all these sounds.
She's...
No.
Stop.
I just want to play Benchmode, ma'am.
I just...
I just wanted to play Benchmode.
I...
Please.
I just...
I...
I can't.
I can't focus.
I just...
Oh my God.
No, I'm slowing down again.
I can't.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I feel a lot more safe now.
This is fine.
Everything is...
Oh my God.
Okay.
I feel...
I just...
Guys.
I'm so flustered right now.
This is not what I expected.
I...
I'm back at 100.
She's...
She's saying things and I'm just like, Ma 'am, I just wanted to hold your hand.
And I...
Oh my God.
Back at 100.
And I...
You're so pretty.
You're really beautiful.
And...
I think you would make...
I think you are a wonderful woman.
And I hope...
I hope...
This is not...
Just a one time thing.
And...
Like that we might be able to see each other again.
I'm sorry.
I'm...
I don't know what I'm doing.
I just wanted to play Bejeweled.
I'm so sorry for making you wait for so long.
And I'm still playing anime Bejeweled.
Because I can't concentrate right now.
And I...
Oh my God.
We're still fucking here.
I'm at 300.
I'm just stumbling chat every time I get close enough.
I just...
I don't know what to do.
Like the highest I've ever got to was 400.
And then she cools down.
And then I'm like, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm trying my best.
But I can't do it that fast.
I'm still learning.
I'm just a young boy.
I did it.
She's not saying anything, guys.
She's not...
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Does she say more stuff?
Does she say anything else?
Because I think I can censor this correctly if I try hard enough.
I think.
Thank God.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Oh my God.
There's no more after this, right?
Oh, it's okay.
Alright.
Okay.
I got a little bit scared.
Okay, we're fine.
We're so fine.
I can...
Okay, that might be a little too risky, but...
Right here.
Alright.
Nixxi, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you as red as this Akasupa right now?
I hope this works.
Wait.
It's not over?!
What?
Alright.
Okay.
There's more?!
How much more?
What the- Oh my God, no!
Okay.
Is there- Is there more?
My bedroom.
My bedroom warning.
Oh, she went back to my place.
Oh my God.
I'll have to give you some pointers next time.
That's fine.
That's...
Wow.
I did it.
I worked so hard.
I worked so hard to succeed.
I worked so hard too!
I got it!
All that effort...
Effort what?!
People are like, go check her profile.
Guys, is it worth...
Guys, is it worth like...
We might not have- We might not have chat.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna put a black bar over it.
Oh my God, all that work.
I played it so perfectly.
At the very end.
Right
at the end was where everything went down.
I just...
I just wanted to look at her profile.
Why would you put that there?
Oh my God, I worked so hard to get to this part of the game.
Alright guys, I'm gonna snip the chat.
The chat will disappear.
Because we're gonna edit the pod.
I can't believe I worked so hard to get to this exact moment.
And we lost it all at the finish.
Like, we were one centimeter away from the finish line.
Just because I looked at the goddamn profile.
Oh,
that build up just got ruined at the end.
I can't help but feel that there's an eye in it.
I could've just closed the game.
We could've just closed the game.
I just had to look at her profile.
I was like, oh cool, what did I unlock by completing that?
I just had to close the game.
She was endgame.
She literally ended my career.
Hey Doki, I don't have to worry about a 9-5 job or rush hour.
Because I have to stream my other monitor while I work.
Great stream, 10 out of 10.
I need to go see my boss now.
Thank you for the super chat, Evian.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Liam, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
No, Kaz, she said she liked being choked, not choking.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Just before I get into any more trouble, I'm going to swap the screen.
I don't want to get into more trouble.
Poor Fodder is one and all.
Bear witness.
Thank you for the super chat, Sterling.
Thank you, you were all there, everybody.
You were all here.
Alright guys, I'm gonna...
Guys, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna put a censor bar in the editing.
To hide, you know...
The one second you were all here.
That was... Wow, that was...
That was an adventure.
And I learned a lot.
And I hope...
And I...
I hope... I hope...
I hope they let me hold hands.
I hope she lets me hold her hand again.
That was...
Wow.
It's part two.
Say thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wow.
We were all here.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wowie.
Alright.
I'm gonna head out now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flow.
And if you stay up for me...
Wow, head to bed.
Cause you all deserve it.
I hope you guys enjoyed...
My adventures of...
Wow.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye bye, guys.
Bye bye.